let's go back to the phones at 6 1 7 8 3
0 47 50 and see what is on people's
minds more people than we have ever had
holding or holding right now let's go to
our caller from the 7 5 7 area code
who's calling today from 7 5 7 hi David
Wow yes you are who's this oh my name is
Sam I'm from Virginia Beach hey I'm
going because I just watched your a
segment that was talking about the
Democratic primary polls yes and regards
obeid okay and you talked at length
about how some people were saying all
the polls are biased and/or bogus and I
made a post on your your reddit page
about it and it's kind of verbose not
anything but just of it was is that the
polls that you referenced in that
segment think it was a console poll of
the Harvard Harris the hill Harris X
polls were kind of an interesting choice
because the morning council Poehler she
said was opaque and didn't really speak
to the issue of aged Rasputin's and the
polling data I think the whole AG was
central to but also because the Harvard
Harris poll and the the hit X poll are
both conducted owned by a private equity
firm called the stag ball group mmm when
I started researching into them and the
stag will group it's kind of private
equity firms controlled by Mark Penn who
is you know notorious Hillary Clinton
strategists and from form have worked in
the Bill Clinton's administration and is
pretty much the Democratic establishment
well don't quote would you agree with
that characterization I'm not sure about
that characterization but let me say a
couple things just to make sure we're on
the same page that you know you called
the the choice of the polls that I used
an interesting choice I just used the
most recent three polls at the time that
I put the segment together so I was
going only with the standard of trying
to get the most recent possible data so
that there was no nothing beyond that
the other thing I think I just what do
you want to mention to you is that a lot
of polling companies are owned by large
corporations rich people etc and that
alone as a disqualifier I would
be skeptical of well it's interesting
because it's a girl group actually
acquired the harbor Harris poll she's
been running for 50 60 years
yes in 2017 after the 2016 primary okay
Harris X which is a PR and data
consulting company primarily Google
Amazon and other companies does is P and
5g technology advertising and now all of
a sudden they're partnering with the
hill to do the data and it's all both of
these companies are under the larger
private umbrella of the stag well group
like I said that it's owned and counted
by work and and like I said it's so much
interesting just because we chose those
polls but also because the issue seems
to be unique to see this poll I found a
video from March where you talked about
how the favorability poll so unit
actually excluded younger voters and I
believe the issue that a lot of people
been providing to you about what
specific to a from CNN and late April
that talked about will have the same
issue it did okay if that's if that's
the poll people were referring to then
maybe that's not a good poll I haven't
looked at that poll but that wouldn't
change my analysis analysis but suppose
I did look at in in any way what's fair
you know I'm not trying to say that
should completely discount the polls
because of the financial backing of
whoever the supporting them well tell me
what you are saying I mean do you think
that the three polls I use are they just
wrong like have they said let's just
give Joe Biden in an extra 5 10 15 20
points like what do you think Joe
Biden's real level of support is well I
think it's a little bit weird when I see
polls essays 36 percent of Millennials
like the one that you posted so I think
the hill Harris ex support Joe Biden
that's just as inconsistent with my
experience of reality this is why what
do you mean I don't think how many
people I don't think a quarter of how
many people I talk to that that's hard
to quantify exactly but I know they talk
to about 500 people I probably talked to
about the same amount of people in my
day-to-day life and my social sphere so
I feel like it's kind of ridiculous and
I know this all anecdotal an individual
experience but I mean 25 percent of
Millennials are supporting Joe Biden
when we have Pete but a gig well the
youngest people running we've got Joe
Biden I mean Bernie Sanders he's got
chemo Harris
just don't you just don't believe the
results right you just don't use it you
think the results are wrong am I right
about that
not exclusively I'm just saying that
there's subversive ways that media
companies can influence by selecting
fair but so then let's say Joe Biden's
level of support really is 36% and you
don't want Biden to be the nominee
what's the best thing that that person
should do well I agree with you here in
somebody you're ultimately but--can that
we can't really focus on colors to
change people's minds but I do think
that if we choose not to focus on
consolidated media apparatus these
private equity firms they're dying of
polls and we're kind of missing the
forest for the trees we're focusing on
the the data all the reams of data and
specific points but we're not looking at
the money to influence that operates on
a higher operational level I think a lot
of people are looking at that I think
either way what people have to do is
just go out and vote for the candidate
they they most agree with all right
thank you for the column and I'll let
you go because I have so many people
wanting to wanting to get on